we've been talking a little bit about
the the rat utopia experiment have you
ever heard of that
no it sounds lovely i don't know i don't
know too much about it other than
um people have chatted us about it but
the general premise was that
they created the space where they put a
bunch of rats in this you know terrarium
kind of thing
unlimited food and water not a care in
the world no threats
and eventually they populated to a
certain point then they
started becoming and they started
changing
some stopped having sex altogether some
stopped eating some just started dying
i think some like started becoming
cannibals it was like a really brutal
once they reached a certain level of
crowding and population
weird things started happening in their
rat society i wonder if
humans have reached a point like that
and i think that's why people bring it
up
to where maybe the reason we're not
hitting families anymore is because we
got we got a ton of people on the planet
as it is
especially psychologically with social
media i in the early days i was like oh
facebook good i'm gonna get all my
friends on facebook and then i'm gonna
be able to i'll be able to message
everybody at once and then i can throw a
big party where i have everyone in my
house and then all of a sudden i had
like
170 people 300 people and i
didn't talk to any of them i was so
overwhelmed that's and that's like
one of the things i said happened with
the rat utopia experiments they're like
crowd and areas just like
in weird ways but i wonder if what
happens is
you know we used to have kids out of
necessity
you know uh that's why if you look at
less developed nations they have lots of
kids
because the kids do jobs right but now
we got washing machines we got
dishwashers we got stoves we got
clean running water in the cities so you
don't need to have kids
maybe it's just a natural state of life
where you find this equilibrium point
where
you just don't need to have kids so
there's no real drive to do it
no no woman no woman goes through
childbirth
because she needs it i mean that like
maybe because she because it's a
because it's not this is like she's
literally putting her life in danger
women have an and a
existential like in her body like
everything
not all women most women to have a child
we do you think every month
we have a violent reminder yeah it's
great of our evolutionary
you know role and it's not it's not the
patriarchy
that created menstruation right we have
it
but i'm not saying that like women sit
there and think to themselves like i'm
gonna have a kid because i need to have
a kid
i'm just saying that pressures begin to
appear
to not have kids one just once a certain
level in a population size
or amount of resources and then it just
becomes less feasible
for people to do that's definitely the
case for men i mean we used to spread
our seed to as many women as possible
and now that's been become taboo in
society so that's an example of
not overpopulating is it taboo
for the most part polygamy is kind of
looked down upon yeah but
promiscuity is through the roof but not
having children all over the place
definitely
doing it i mean yeah i guess you'd be
frowned upon in any capacity the old
trope was that the guy would be chased
out of the farmhouse by the day with a
shotgun you know who was sleeping with
the farmer's daughter or whatever
all that alimony well it was because you
have to make like
shotgun wedding you know you're gonna
take care of this kid and you've you've
just committed yourself to doing it
these days it's like swipe on tinder you
just sit there and you swipe non-stop
and then just do whatever you want and
it's encouraged
back in the old day like i'm thinking of
zeus you know all these ancient well he
had like 40 kids and then he had kids
with his kids it like
because they needed to populate they
were like yeah well they're recovering
from
those those are stories yeah but but
like did he turn himself into a duck and
then bang a woman or something wow
what a weird story yeah maybe it was
real maybe it wasn't but i think that
that behavior wasn't so taboo as it is
today and where
so whereas women have the burning desire
to have children
men have the burning desire to have to
spread their seed and we've had to kind
of culturally
subdue that because it doesn't mix with
modern day
you know society like too many kids
without fathers would be very bad for
society well
it's bad for the kids kids who are born
with
who don't have a father father figure in
the household are more likely to be poor
more likely not to graduate high school
more likely to end up in jail
so men have a very important role in
society
and again it just keeps you've asked you
know well what can we do
and unfortunately you know it's too late
for
the millennial and gen x generations to
change that
although certainly men can stand up and
do better
and they can raise they can be there for
boys and even if you're not a father
if you're an uncle or if you're a friend
of the family you could be there for a
boy
and you can help raise that boy that is
such a gift to that boy because that boy
will grow up to reach his potential
if he has that but um unfortunately
we have you know kids who
aren't growing up without dads and it
just keeps
you know going around and around the
same circle um
so i look again
women generally want to be moms not all
women
women want to be moms and it is it is
devastating
when she's doing everything she can
she's doing all the right things
she's contributing to society it's like
she's doing everything she can
and i agree with you that a guy
who's you know her equal in terms of
you know career income what have you
he you know she's 35 he's 35 he can
easily marry a 25 year old
what happened to her right so it is but
it's devastating to those women the
level of
of i mean i've i have grieved not having
children i'm
i'm beyond hope of having children and
so i've
moved on from that but certainly i mean
and it's and it's elongated now because
it used to be that a woman you know hit
a certain age 40 plus or minus
she was no longer fertile couldn't have
children but today
let's say egg freezing well there's
still hope
or even ivf there's still hope all this
technology people will tell you
oh but my kids my cousin's sister's
neighbor had twins at 45.
still hope so what does that do it
creates this longer
time of grief for this woman and it's
really hard
so i i i'm again a champion of boys and
i think we need to go back and look at
education
how we are educating boys how we're
making sure that they have male role
models
how we're letting them play encouraging
them to play all of those things right
i think that we also on the men's side
need to be a little bit more sympathetic
to women they're not desperate because
they really want to go out with you
again
because they like you they're not
desperate because they want to have a
baby and they're 36
they're women and they want to be moms
and that's perfectly normal and it
doesn't make them weak it makes them
strong
to be able to admit that that's what
they want and if you're a guy who's
going to lead a woman on
and just because you know you don't
really want i don't know well maybe
we'll try well maybe next year
when i get a raise you know what her
fertility doesn't have time for your
excuses
so if you love her or if you don't love
her let her go
or get married and be a man
so there's a i guess it's a stereotype
maybe there's actual data behind this
i've not
read it that men tend to be goal
oriented and women tend to be social
oriented
so a guy derives his joy from
accomplishing something that dopamine
hit whereas women from social acceptance
and i don't know if that's true
but it does kind of play into the story
about how young women are becoming
depressed because of social media
they go on instagram they take they take
a selfie they post it
it doesn't get enough likes they delete
it right away and it does affect guys
but not as much sure i've noticed
something really interesting when i when
i watch skateboarding videos on
instagram
i noticed that there are a lot of videos
of guys skateboarding and actually you
know what i'm not even talking about
skateboarding
when guys take photos of things or when
they post things it's an object
yeah when women do it it's of them of
course yeah so i even know female
journalists
and it's the weirdest thing to me where
they're like on the ground in the middle
east
and they're taking a selfie of
themselves with like the thing in the
background and i'm like
just show the tank like you know and
then what guys do is they'll post the
video of just the tank with themselves
not in it yeah
so i wonder if that also plays a very
serious role
that the reason women are hyper focusing
on work is because society
because of what would be deemed
acceptable and this is stemming from
when you look at news media and cultural
media
the women who are working these jobs are
mostly career women
not all of them and then you end up with
a tendency to only get the positive
social message from women who are not
married
who are working careers then telling
younger women
this is the right way to do it this is
what's great and because of the
social pressure they do and that's
perpetuating this
this cycle yeah
there are no career women it's not like
women are choosing to have a career
women have to work
we do what else we supposed to do get
married at a young age i guess
and siphon off the man or have a
traditional family i'm not
i guess raising a kid's worth more than
money that's for sure
but it's not like they're choosing
career over
love marriage and motherhood i didn't do
that
most women aren't doing that well what's
why what's stopping them from
having a relationship then so my mom
actually asked me this because she and i
were talking about millennial women and
why they don't really appear
to want to get married and or have kids
and i said mom we can't afford to
we can't afford rent where we were
living rent was like 14 or 1500 bucks a
month and i was like there's no way to
afford rent and also have children
unless you are both working and i was
like i don't want to do that i want to
be able to actually raise my kids
and that means like part-time work or
not working at all and being like a
stay-at-home mom
right it's very much a matter of money i
think you're right yeah no it is it's
like
how did how did how did the families do
it i don't know 300 years ago
we walk into the woods with a check we
don't have that anymore
the economy today means that most
most women and men have to work
what else are we going to do and
especially when a woman
why shouldn't a woman work why shouldn't
a woman have a career it's
and i don't mean this in the feminist
way i'm in the you know
traditional feminist way i just mean it
like why not you know that's not
feminism that's just being human like
why shouldn't she reach her potential
that doesn't mean that she like for
instance again me right
i very much wanted to be married and
have children i had
a baby name book when i was 12. i mean i
had planned my wedding in my
family backyard i this was what i wanted
and it didn't happen not because i
didn't want
it but if i didn't have as well like
when i was in my late 30s that's when i
decided to create my own company
because i didn't know if i was going to
have some legacy and that's in the end
part of why we have children we want to
know we're going to leave something
we want if it's not literal dna then
maybe it's some sort of intellectual dna
there's something we can leave behind
and so that's why women have
careers because they need to be able to
pay the rent etc and
and by the way if they do meet a guy
he's divorced because the 22 year old he
married really wasn't
exactly what he needed because she
didn't really she was much more
interested in
her body and her selfies than in him and
in helping him be the best he can be
and he then finds this you know 40 year
old woman
who's amazing because they're the same
age and actually share the same
conversations
intellect experience etc and and he's
okay well we'll have a kid together okay
but
where was she going to get the money for
the ivf or for the eggs that she froze
i mean careers pay for things and part
of it is it it gives her a safety net
for her fertility thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you